has to blend in
no no they're on the calendar someone's
drawn a little hard
right above today's day
oh yes the heart
[Music]
told you it was all connected
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who's miles
ahead when it comes to marvel theories
and the spider-man noah home trailer has
a lot to talk about in it i have just
done a big trailer breakdown discussing
all of the easter eggs in hidden details
i thought i'd take some time to focus
more on the theories that i have about
the movie that might hopefully clear up
some of the confusion also i need to
milk this yeah i'm self-employed i've
gotta milk the popular topics now i am
basing a lot of these theories on comic
books so if marvel decide to adapt them
then there might be some spoilers ahead
if you enjoy the video then please hit
the thumbs up button and don't forget to
subscribe for breakdowns like this each
and every day without the way thank you
for clicking this now let's get into our
spider-man no way home trailer theories
okay so the first thing i want to talk
about is how this all ties into the
quote-unquote multiverse quadrilogy set
up by marvel whilst it's pretty obvious
that variants and realities will all
feature heavily in a lot of the mcu
going forward kevin feige said that one
division loki spider-man no way home and
doctor strange 2 would all be heavily
linked it is rumored that loki will
actually feature in in the multiverse of
madness and that wonder will also be the
villain i actually think that this movie
will lean heavily into that and judging
by what we know from the comics i think
this film will tease what's gonna happen
next with strange he features heavily in
the first look and if we look at the
happy birthday storyline then it seems
like this movie is going to pull several
elements from it now during that book
dormammu attacks new york and strange
attempts to stop him he casts a spell
but spider-man interrupts this and it
breaks reality and time-wide open this
is of course similar to what happens in
the trailer when peter interferes
mid-spell with strange trying to erase
the knowledge that peter parker is
spider-man peter ends up seeing his past
and future and he also fights several
villains from his rogues gallery which
this movie seems to be setting up too
the book ends with strange being
punished by other sorcerers for breaking
time and all these similarities mean
that he could be having to deal with the
consequences of this wonder is currently
the universe's most powerful witch i
think if we're following on from a
multiversal storyline that's strange
versus her just makes a lot of sense now
speaking of the spell after watching the
trailer several times and really sitting
on it i actually think that it does
indeed wipe mj's memory and peter is
pretty much completely alone in who
knows that he's spider-man why i say
this is because of the behind-the-scenes
images and footage of the film in which
we see peter going to meet the character
now because he's not getting mobbed i
guess everything works but it looks like
he's asking her out on a date i think it
would be kind of heartbreaking if it
turned out that she no longer remembered
him and this is basically them having to
start the entire relationship again at
one point in the trailer mj asks if
there's any part of him that's relieved
about his name being out there because
he no longer has to lie and peter says
he never wanted to lie to her i think it
would be such a great twist to have it
so he's back in this position again and
having to decide whether to tell her or
not because of all the issues it could
cause now this idea of erasing people's
memories actually pulls from the one
more day storyline and though strange
appears in that to attempt to help peter
it's actually mephisto who comes through
in the end when i was reading the
comments on my last video i saw that a
lot of you started theorizing that
strange might actually be mephisto and i
began to feel a bit like the doctor in
terminator you know the lad you've saw
terminator
he well he saw terminator 2 he knew it
was a terminator convinced himself it
wasn't only to realize that it was
actually a terminator well that's
basically what happened with me and
mephisto and that devil in disguise
poster
whoo let's let's just not get into it
again now i don't know if this is
actually the case but let's be honest
strange is acting very weird in the
teaser and at one point he even chases
peter now this could be a number of
things and potentially the writers just
wrote the character to be like this as
sometimes you know writers they just
portray characters in certain ways in
order to fit the story however yeah it
could be mephisto but i actually have a
completely different theory potentially
when strange rips the multiverse open
he's actually switched out with the
darker variant of himself i don't know
who said it on the last video as the
comments are going wild right now
million in a day in a day but let's just
say it was you for argument's sake now
in the last video you actually theorize
that the movie will tie in with what if
and we know that at some point in the
season that strange will come across an
alternate darker version of himself when
discussing the series brian andrews
director of the show also brought up
that entry specifically and said the
following the doctor strange episode is
a tour de force it ends in a particular
way you'll know it when you see it when
they actually see it they're going to be
like i can't believe they did that [ __ ]
so it might be the case that we watched
the old switcheroo happen there though
it could be the captain caught a shot
that we also saw in the trailer i'm
leaning more towards that but it would
at least make people realize why the old
dock is acting different however there
is one more theory and in superhero
nexus's breakdown for the trailer he
said it could be agatha harkness not
only does strange wink similar to how
she does but he also casts a spell in
the basement similar to our aggie i'll
link his video below if you want to see
it discuss more in detail i think that's
a really good idea that yeah it's
definitely worth including now in our
last video we also said that we think
it's matt murdock who slams the papers
down on the police desk many of you said
he looked a bit too fat to be mad and
from this point onwards he shall be
known as
fat murdock however i do think that it's
charlie cox and when we see the guy
outside the interrogation room he looks
very similar let's just stop body
shaming the lad yeah i'm gonna be honest
i put a couple of pounds on during
lockdown we all did those donuts were
delicious now as for all the villains in
the movie i think it's safe to say that
the multiverse is completely [ __ ] at
this point whilst there is potential
that it's a jay jonah jameson situation
where the actor is just reprising an mc
version of the character judging by what
we know of the film i think that they
will definitely be pulled from the
multiverse alfred molina stated that his
character comes into the movie in a
scene that mirrors the river one from
the end of spider-man 2. and thus we can
gather from this that each featured
villain is going to be from an alternate
reality now whether they are the same
versions or not we don't know for
definite but in the trailer i counted
several of them including awk the green
goblin electro and sandman sandman
actually looks like he's going to be one
of the good guys and he uses his body at
one point to stop an electro blast
making me think that he's on peter's
side saman was very much a tragic figure
in the raimi verse and therefore i can
see him switching teams now if we are
building towards the sinister six
appearing in the movie then that does
leave a couple of openings there's only
five villains in the trailer and whilst
the plot leaks say that the rhino is the
final one
i actually think that it's gonna be
someone else in the mcu we very much
dealt with the idea of identity in the
post-credits scenes of the spidey films
homecoming ended with ant-may finding
out that peter was spider-man and the
post-credits scene had matt gorgan going
directly to the vulture and asking him
if he knew who spider-man was the one in
far from home led to peter's identity
being exposed i think if they don't
bring gogen in as the scorpion then
that's a big missed opportunity if
there's only five members and the
sandman also allies himself with the
good guys and it just leaves a big space
for scorpion and we might even get the
vulture featuring as a member though i
think he's also another character that
wouldn't hurt peter
now where this theory falls down is the
whole memory erasure thing but i think
it just makes a lot of sense to have
gorgon as a sinister six member
especially as he could be the one that's
tied to the universe whilst the others
are tourists that final space could also
end up being filled by one of peter's
most evil villains someone that has
stalked his entire existence and a man
that's followed his footsteps constantly
peering over his shoulder now that of
course is mr dikovich and that door that
door ain't gonna pay for itself mate now
i do think that the green goblin will be
the leader of the group rather than ok
and i would say that they've shown him
over willem dafoe's version because this
is a first teaser and they don't want to
blow all of their web shooters in the
first look therefore i think dafoe is
going to be the one heading things up
and that the encounter with ark will
happen in the middle of the movie
by the looks of it the sinister six
won't be the only people that peter has
to deal with either and it looks like
he'll be going toe-to-toe with strange
at some point he might be the missing
sinister six member we don't know now i
absolutely love the chase through new
york and the mirror dimension is an
incredible place to have an action scene
play out whether this completely
destroys their friendship or not we
don't know but if it leads to new york
being attacked by some of the biggest
villains in the marvel universe then you
can imagine that strange won't be happy
now i actually think that the film will
have the death of ant-may in it at some
point if we look at the comics namely
the civil war storyline peter unmasked
for the world to see in order to show
that the sokovia records worked and this
action had dire consequences kingpin
sent assassins after him and they
critically injured mae trying to get to
him there's a scene in the trailer where
may and peter set up in their apartment
almost like someone is walking in she is
notably absent in the majority of the
trailer and at one point it looks like
mj and peter are living together in a
completely new apartment which makes me
think they had to find somewhere else to
live happy also gets a swat team put on
him which could be under a crime bosses
command and just looking at everything i
think that might be what happens in the
film again these are all theories and
they know that will have holes in them i
doubt i've got all of them right yeah
but maybe it's one but i thought yeah i
just put them together after seeing the
trailer and just watching it obsessively
since it dropped these are things i
didn't get a chance to really talk about
in the initial breakdown and it was 20
minutes long and i just didn't want to
keep rambling and rambling for another
10 minutes so if yeah if you watch that
thanks for coming over here but if you
haven't watched it then then go and
watch it yeah you pick the wrong one if
you pick this first i'll tell you that
now we are running a competition right
now and giving away three mz box sets on
the 30th of august and all you have to
do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and just give your
thoughts on the trailer we picked the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one on
screen right now so that's you then
message me on twitter at heavy spoilers
if not then thank you for sitting with
me until the end of the video i've been
paul i'll see you next time take care
yourself peace